Morning. Sprint planning. Before the board, one carry-over from last week.
Priya, the churn analysis you were writing up. Did that go out?
Not yet. I got pulled into the incident on Tuesday and it slipped. It's still on my list.
Fine, but people are making plans on the assumption it exists. Can we say end of this week?
End of this week, yes. I'll block Thursday morning for it.
While we're on it, the pricing decision from last week — is that final, or are we reopening?
It's final for launch. We delay the increase. Whether we revisit in Q3 is a separate conversation.
Good, because I've told two customers we're holding prices. I'd rather not walk that back.
You're safe. Right, the board. We've got fourteen points of migration cleanup queued.
That's most of the sprint. The rollback tooling is the big one and I don't want to split it.
Can we take the rollback work and leave the smaller bugs? Otherwise nothing lands.
That works. I'll take rollback tooling. Someone else needs to own the bug triage.
I'll own triage. Decision: rollback tooling this sprint, small bugs deferred to next.
Noted. And I still owe everyone the churn numbers by Thursday.